DANNY (VOICEOVER): A few
months back, we got a really
special bike in the shop.
It's a 1957
Harley-Davidson Panhead
prototype, made by famous
customizers, S&S Cycles.
This baby hadn't been
started in 20 years,
and getting her up and
running wasn't easy.
If anybody was up to the
task, it's my man, Shannon.
We completely restored and
repainted this beautiful piece
of history.
And she looks better than
new, if I do say so myself.
DANNY: What's up?
EARNEST: There's
the man himself.
DANNY (VOICEOVER): Earnest is
here today with his son-in-law,
Rex, to pick this bike up.
And he's sure been
through a lot in his life,
and I'm hoping that
today, we can make things
a little bit better for him.
DANNY: Rex, you
brought us this bike.
Heck yeah.
Why did you bring it to us?
Because we heard
you're the best there is.
That's what I like to hear.
Ernest, let me ask you, man,
when did you buy this bike?
1977.
This bike has history.
And it's beautiful.
It's beautiful.
You want to see your bike?
- Yeah!
He can't wait to get his bike.
Come here, come
here, come here.
Just hang out right here.
Shannon!
Come on, man.
Bring out that Panhead.
[engine revving]
You hear that?
That's your bike.
- No way.
Aw, man!
[horn beeps]
Aw, you Did it.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
DANNY (VOICEOVER): We wanted
to keep this historic prototype
as original as possible,
but she desperately needed
a tune-up from head to toe.
Shannon worked his magic
and got her running
again while preserving the
original engine, front-end,
and seat.
He also painstakingly
fabricated a brand new rear
fender to match the original.
Then Ryan topped her off with
a beautiful new paint job,
using a candy apple red with
gold leafing, not to mention
the stunning portrait of
Ernest's beloved Betty,
so that he could always take
her memory along for the ride.
EARNEST: Oh, you
guys are awesome!
DANNY: Look at this.
Look at this.
Come on, man.
- It's so great.
You brought to
us what I consider
a historically-significant
motorcycle.
This is what I would call
a mule bike, test bike.
This bike had a lot of
first-off, prototype things
that S&S did.
Shannon made sure
that the integrity
of the history of this
motorcycle was kept intact.
SHANNON: The sheet metal
is original, Earnest,
except for the rear fender.
I had to build you
a new rear fender.
Around the light is all steel.
There's no there's
no Bondo fixed up.
That came out beautiful.
And here's the
thing about the seat.
There was something about
that seat that said,
there's history here.
There's importance here.
So the bike is brand new,
but the seat tells the story.
Yeah.
George Smith at S&S, they
wanted to buy the bike back.
I said, call this guy, not me.
But they did give me a
brand new S&S carburetor,
so that's what's on your bike.
So that's a brand new S&S carb.
DANNY: Ryan, this paint.
REX: That paint job
is just awesome.
God.
Tell me about this, man.
Ernie, when Rex
brought the bike in,
it had an old, faded,
candy paint job.
It needed to be freshened up.
And I needed a little class.
And that's why I added the gold
leaf pin-striping on there.
And of course, the
picture of Betty.
That her?
- Oh my god.
Yeah.
- Is it correct?
All right.
[kiss]
- Yeah.
Yeah.
Is that what you
had in mind, Ernie?
DANNY: As you enjoy this
bike, as you ride this bike,
as you go out and
have fun on this bike.
Bettie.
She'll be with you.
This bike obviously
means a lot to Ernest,
and I love being able to
take something like this back
to her former glory.
I know after 20 years he
can't wait to hop on this baby
and take her for a ride.
I just got to say man, thank you
for bringing us this project.
Gentlemen.
Rex.
Thank you.
Thank you, my man.
Thank you guys.